welcome back so in the last video what
we saw was essentially how dynamics
linear dynamical systems change under
some invertible coordinate
transformation from x coordinates to z
coordinates they basically turn into you
know instead of a b and c we have these
a hat b hat and c hats which are simple
functions of my original dynamics here
and we also saw how that transformed my
Grammie and so my new controllability
granion in these new coordinates is this
expression in terms of my old dream IAM
and my new observability granion looks
like this also so i want to work through
a really simple example and I should
point out all of this balance model
reduction really started with this very
very important seminal paper by Moore in
I think 1981 very great paper you should
all go read it it's a classic now
basically he laid the foundation for the
fact that there are these
transformations that had this property
of balancing my Grammie ins making these
equal and diagonal and then he showed
you how to actually do it with a real
system and then he showed us how to do
it with data so everything we're doing
is kind of in the spirit of Moore 1981 I
believe this is an I Triple E
transactions on automatic control paper
but don't quote me on that
so as a really simple example I just
want to show you kind of what we would
be doing here to balance these let's
start with a really really simple
example in x coordinates we're gonna
have good ok D DT of x1 x2 equals and
I'm going to make this minus 1 0 0 minus
10 so I'm going to make this a decoupled
dynamical system just because it's
easier to think about ok we don't have
to do this but it's much easier if I do
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
have a system state that's 10 to the
minus 3 10 to the plus 3 you so notice
that my first state is much harder for
you to control than my second state it's
like you impacts the first date way way
way more aggressively and then I'm going
to have my measurement y equals
10 to the 3 10 to the minus 3 so in this
case it's the exact opposite
notice that my first state is way easier
to measure than my second state this is
minus 3 this is plus 3 okay so this is
just a kind of really exaggerated toy
system in fact this is basically
modified from an example that Moore gave
in his 1981 paper ok so what I could do
a very simple balancing transformation
if I if I went through I would find that
that the x1 state is the x2 state is
super controllable and the x1 state is
super observable basically okay so these
would be kind of perpendicular grampians
where X x-2 is much more controllable
than x1 and x1 is much more observable
than x2 and this simple example is going
to show us how a tea matrix could
actually make this balanced and find a
state that's mote that's equally
controllable and observable so the the
state we're gonna do now is we're gonna
say okay Z this is just a super simple
z1 and z2 z1 is going to equal 10 to the
3 times X 1 and Z 2 is going to equal 10
to the minus 3 times X 2 this seems just
ridiculously simple and you could write
this as a matrix if you want it I could
say this is Z equals 10 to the 3 0 0 10
to the minus 3 times X and I could
invert that to get T ok this is a T
matrix this is T inverse what this is
doing all I'm doing is rescaling x1 I'm
making it a thousand times bigger and
I'm rescaling x2 to make it a thousand
times smaller that's all I'm doing
that's what the T matrix does is just
rescales my state but what we're going
to find is that in those new Z
coordinates we actually get balanced
dynamics the inputs and the outputs are
somehow balanced so let's write this DDT
of Z and I'm pretty sure we can just
write this down Z - so what's DDT ok DDT
of z1 is my dynamics don't change
okay because even though I pick up ten
to the minus three I also have a ten to
the minus three over here so those
cancel out
so my dynamics don't change my a matrix
stays exactly the same you can verify
you can go through this procedure and
figure out that your a matrix doesn't
change because it's diagonal and this is
diagonal okay so nothing changes this is
Z 1 Z 2 but what's going to be
dramatically different are these B hats
and C hat vectors so this is where it
gets really interesting I'm gonna just
write this all out okay so you now
effects what I did was I made this x1
state I multiplied it by a thousand okay
so now I'm amplifying x1 by a factor of
a thousand and so essentially what that
does if you go through this T inverse B
is it makes this a thousand times bigger
and I made x2 a thousand times smaller
it makes this a thousand times smaller
so what this does to my B matrix is 1 1
and I want you to actually go through
I'm going fast I want you at home to go
through and take these ABC matrices and
this is T inverse and compute T and then
compute a hat B hat and C hat and verify
that what I'm doing here is correct okay
I'm just kind of taking this for granted
similarly if I make this 1 if I scale
this one up and this one down because x1
is the inverse of T I have to like
divide z1 by a thousand and divides and
multiplies each you by a thousand these
also get balanced to one and one long
story short what we're finding is even
if I had dynamics that looked terribly
unbalanced right this is as bad as it
can get this mode was ultra controllable
and this mode was barely controllable
and the opposite was true this was very
very observable and this was barely
observable this was just an artifact of
how I chose to write X maybe I wrote I
don't know x1 in millimeters and I wrote
x2 in kilometers that was stupid
so what Z does is it writes them both in
meters that make sense x1 up here was
written in millimeter in millimeters x2
is written in kilometers so these
numbers just looked artificially off
what i do is i coordinate transform so
that now everything's in meters I
multiply this by a thousand I divide
this by a thousand and when I write them
in meters I get these balance dynamics
where now x1 and x2 are equally
controllable and observable okay that's
kind of an extreme example but this is
just a cartoon of what we're going to be
doing and I wanted to show you this on a
two-by-two decoupled linear system
because eventually what more did he
showed how you could do this for a
thousand by thousand or million by
million system where the intuition is a
little bit less obvious so this is for
building intuition now we're going to
scale this up to really big systems
we're going to design a tea matrix that
balances my Grammie ins that's coming up
next
thank you